[Music]
foreign
Fraser transforming into character for
the whale do you ever
heard now
people are incapable
of not caring people are amazing
the film's production company a24 posted
a time lapse of the process to Instagram
showcasing Brendan's impressive
Evolution into 600 pound man Charlie
don't have to be angry at the whole
world
just be angry at me
Brendan's been up to six hours a day in
that makeup chair putting on nearly 300
pounds of Prosthetics the point is that
he's a person he's a man and he's so
much more than who he would appear to be
to the world and it's so easy to be
cynical and dismissed with others that
way when we know the challenge of
connecting with those is what brings us
closest together the whale marks
Brandon's big return to acting and fans
are coining it his Renaissance I never
anticipated what this moment would feel
like because I had no idea I'm still
pretty new to this so you'll forgive me
if I'm trying to get used to it
um
maybe I never will and that's okay
but I know I'm grateful the role is
nabbing the actor tons of awards season
love and for Brendan he's only just
getting used to it all I would have
known what to do with it 20 25 years ago
it would have been too much too soon so
now that I'm 54. I feel more comfortable
more qualified more confident yeah it
seems Brendan's already come a long way
since the movie's debut at the Venice
Film Festival
I still feel like I'm just getting
started to tell you the truth
I'm not done yet
we're young and ambitious still it's
gonna it's gonna be an interesting
Journey it's It's Not Over
foreign